a confession I am an archaeologist and a
museum curator but a paradoxical one for
my museum I collect things but I also
return things back to where they came
from I love museums because they're
social and educational but I'm most
drawn to them because of the magic of
objects a 1 million year old hand ax a
totem pole an impressionist painting all
take us beyond our own imaginations in
museums we pause to muse to gaze upon
our human Empire things in meditation
and wonder I understand why US museums
alone hosts more than 850 million visits
each year yet in recent years museums
have become a battleground communities
around the world don't want to see their
culture and distant institutions which
they have no control over they want to
see their cultural treasures repatriated
returned to their places of origin
Greece seeks the return of the Parthenon
Marbles a collection of classical
sculptures held by the British Museum
Egypt demands antiquities from Germany
New Zealand Maori want to see returned
ancestral tattooed heads from museums
everywhere yet these claims pale in
comparison to those made by Native
Americans already u.s. museums have
returned more than 1 million artifacts
and fifty thousand sets of Native
American skeletons to illustrate what's
at stake let's start with the war gods
this is a wood carving made by members
of the Zuni tribe in New Mexico in 1880s
anthropologists began to collect them as
evidence of American Indian religion
they came to be seen as beautiful the
precursor to the stark sculpture
of Picasso and Paul clay helping to
usher in the modern art movement from
one viewpoint the museum did exactly as
it's supposed to with the war god it
helped introduce a little-known art form
for the world to appreciate but from
another point of view the museum had
committed a terrible crime of cultural
violence for zuni's the war god is not a
piece of art it is not even a thing it
is a being for zuni's every year priests
ritually carve new war gods the AHA Yuda
breathing life into them in a long
ceremony they are placed on sacred
shrines where they live to protect the
Zuni people and keep the universe in
balance no one can own or sell a war God
they belong only to the earth and so
zuny's want them back from museums so
they can go to their shrine homes to
fulfill their spiritual purpose what is
a curator to do I believe that the war
gods should be returned this might be a
startling answer after all my conclusion
contradicts the refrain of the world's
most famous archaeologist the Hat
belongs in a museum is what is what
Indiana Jones said not just to drive
movie plots but to drive home the
unquestionable good of museums for
society I did not come to my view easily
I grew up in Tucson Arizona and fell in
love with the Sonoran deserts past I was
amazed that beneath the city's bland
strip malls was 12,000 years of history
just waiting to be discovered when I was
16 years old I started taking
archaeology classes and going out on
digs a high school teacher of mine even
helped me set up my own laboratory to
study animal bones but in college
I came to learn that my future career
had a dark history starting in the 1860s
Native American skeletons became a tool
for science collected in the thousands
to prove new theories of social and
racial hierarchies Native American human
remains were plundered from graves even
taken fresh from battlefields when
archaeologists came across white graves
the skeleton was often quickly reburied
while Native bones were deposited as
specimens on museum shelves in the wake
of war stolen lands boarding schools
laws banning religion anthropologists
collected sacred objects in the belief
that native peoples were on the cusp of
extinction you can call it racism or
colonialism but the labels don't matter
as much as the fact that over the last
century Native American rights and
culture were taken from them in 1990
after years of Native protests the US
government through the US Congress
finally passed a law that allowed Native
Americans to reclaim cultural items
sacred objects and human arraigns from
museums many archaeologists were
panicked for scientists it can be hard
to fully grasp how a piece of wood can
be a living God or how spirits surround
bones and they knew that modern science
especially with DNA can provide luminous
insights into the past as the
anthropologist Frank nor Ric declared we
are doing important work that benefits
all of mankind
we are not returning anything to anyone
as a college student all of this was an
enigma that was hard to decipher why did
Native Americans want their heritage
back from the very places preserving it
and how could scientists spend their
entire lives studying dead Indians but
seem to care so little
about living ones I graduated but wasn't
sure what to do next so I traveled one
day in South Africa I visited Nelson
Mandela's former prison cell on Robben
Island I had an epiphany here was a man
who helped a country bridge vast divides
to seek however imperfectly
reconciliation I'm no Mandela but I
asked myself could I to plant seeds of
Hope in the ruins of the past in 2007 I
was hired as a curator at the Denver
Museum of Nature and Science
our team agreed that unlike many other
institutions we needed to proactively
confront the legacy of Museum collecting
we started with the skeletons in our
closet 100 of them after months and then
years we met with dozens of tribes to
figure out how to get these remains home
and this is hard work it involves
negotiating who will receive the remains
how to respectfully transfer them where
will they go Native American leaders
become Undertaker's planning funerals
for dead relatives I'd never wanted
unearthed a decade later the Denver
Museum and our Native partners have
reburied nearly all of the human remains
in the collection we've returned
hundreds of sacred objects but I've come
to see that these battles are endless
repatriation is now a permanent feature
of the museum world hundreds of tribes
are waiting their turn there are always
more museums with more stuff every
catalogued War God in an American public
museum has now been returned 106 so far
but there are more beyond the reach of
US law in private collections and
outside our borders in 2014 I had the
chance to travel with a respected
religious leader from the Zuni tribe
named Octavius Ottawa to visit five
museums in Europe with
God's at the ethnological Museum of
Berlin we saw a war god with a history
of dubious care an overly enthusiastic
curator had added chicken feathers to it
its necklace had once been stolen at the
musee du Quai Branly in paris an
official told us that the war god there
is now state property with no provisions
for repatriation he insisted that the
war god no longer serves zuni's but
museum visitors he said we give all the
objects to the world at the British
Museum we were warned that the Zuni case
would establish a dangerous precedent
for bigger disputes such as the
Parthenon Marbles claimed by Greece
after visiting the five museums
Octavius returned home to his people
empty-handed he later told me it hurts
my heart to see the yahudah so far away
they all belong together it's like a
family member that's missing from a
family dinner when one is gone
their strength is broken I wish that my
colleagues in Europe and Beyond could
see that the war gods do not represent
the end of museums but the chance for a
new beginning when you walk the halls of
a museum you're likely just seeing about
1% of the total collections the rest is
in storage even after returning 500
cultural items and skeletons my museum
still retains 99.999 percent of its
total collections though we no longer
have war gods we have Zuni traditional
pottery jewelry tools clothing and arts
and even more precious than these
objects are the relationships that we
formed with Native Americans through the
process of repatriation now we can ask
Sunnis to share their culture with us
not long ago I had the chance to visit
the returned war gods a shrine sits up
high atop a Mesa overlooking beautiful
Zuni homeland
the shrine is enclosed by a roofless
stone building threaded at the top with
barbed wire to ensure that they're not
stolen again and there they are inside
the Ohio des 106 War gods amid offerings
of turquoise cornmeal she'll even
t-shirts a modern gift to ancient beings
and standing there I got a glimpse at
the war God's true purpose in the world
and it occurred to me then that we do
not get to choose the histories that we
inherit museum curators today did not
pillage ancient graves or steal
spiritual objects but we can accept
responsibility for correcting past
mistakes we can help restore dignity
hope and humanity to Native Americans
the very people who were once the
voiceless objects of our curiosity and
this doesn't even require us to fully
understand others beliefs only that we
respect them museums are temples to
things past now they must also become
places for living cultures as I turned
to walk away from the shrine I drank in
the warm summer air and I watched an
eagle turn lazy circles high above I
thought of the zuni's whose offerings
ensure that their culture is not dead
and gone but alive and well and I could
think of no better place for the war
gods to be thank you
[Applause]
[Music]